now some of you have said to me i could
do the question
because the answers were there because
it's multi-choice so i went through and
i picked and one worked
and then it was fine but the question
was well how do you actually do it if
you don't get given
the answers uh what is
um what is x plus hold on let me read
the exams
um all right then i want to know what f
of x is
okay what's f of x okay now
to try and understand this question um
it would have been better actually if it
was an equivalent sign but it doesn't
really matter
you've got to try and wrap your head
around what's the question even asking
okay so to try and explain that let me
try and draw your mind back to this
which you think has nothing to do with
this question
but actually has everything to do with
this question okay
what is this no seriously what is it
this is trig more specifically it's
auxiliary angle isn't it
okay now this is actually very
interesting
you take two wave functions oscillating
things right
and you add them together no matter what
their amplitudes are you can put them
together and get another wave function
but how can you do that apart from
actually drawing it and doing additional
ordinance
how did we prove it well you just look
at this left hand side
right and you know there's expansions we
learn trig expansions
and when you expand the sky you will get
something very similar to this
but the coefficients will be a little
different won't they instead of being
a's and b's
they'll be in terms of r's and alphas
okay
so the idea i'm trying to get across to
you though is what you have on both
sides of the equivalence
is the same kind of function just sort
of dressed up in different clothes
okay and that's what you have here okay
now you're used to saying
oh f of x equals x squared plus two
it's a function it's in terms of x okay
but they're telling you this function is
not actually in terms of x it's in terms
of
x plus two you're like what does that
even mean okay
well let's think about this if i gave
you a function
in terms of say theta okay
i could have written this sine
two theta plus cos theta there you go
there's a function in terms of theta is
that okay
i can give you a function in terms of y
i could write
e to the y plus log y that's a function
in terms of y okay so what might a
function look like
if it was in terms of x plus 2
as a thing right well you can think of
some functions in terms of x plus 2.
um you know this would be a function
times x 2 log of x
plus 2 plus the absolute value of x plus
2. i don't even know what life looks
like it looks like something
and the point is that the variable i'm
interested in is x plus 2. i stick it in
all these places
you get a function okay
but hold on they're telling me this
function of x plus 2
is not just going to be anything
okay you actually are very very limited
in the kinds of candidates you can
choose
for example i know whatever f
x is it's not going to be this
i know it's not because there's no trick
here where would this tree go where
would it disappear answer nowhere
it can't be this either there are no
exponentials or logs or absolute
maybe anyway it's not though okay i'm
very limited if what i've got on the
right hand side is a quadratic
just like what i've got on the right
hand series tree right the left hand
side has got to be the same kind of
family just
dressed up in different clothes okay you
see this is in terms of x
this in terms of x plus alpha what might
this thing look like
what's a quadratic in x plus 2
just like this is a quadratic in x
so i could write a quadratic like this
that's a quadratic in x isn't it
in fact that's the only kind of
quadratic index that exists for
different values of a b and c
right so what would a quadratic in x
plus two
look like
that's not just a quadratic in x plus 2
that's every quadratic
in x plus 2 depending on what a b and c
are
now i don't want anyone i want the
specific one
that ends up looking like this
okay so how did we work this thing out
well you use a trig extension
and then you compare both sides right
i'm going to do
exactly the same thing here let's just
get rid of all of this
other rubbish that i don't need what am
i going to do well i'm going to use a
an expansion but it's not very fancy it
doesn't have a cool name like the true
expansion it's just
it's just the expansion of x plus 2
squared what is x plus 2 all squared
that's x squared plus
4x plus 4. whoa
crazy identities here okay what's the
rest of this
this is b x plus two b plus c
that's apparently all equal to x squared
plus two that's what they're telling you
that's what the first line says
okay now i can't quite compare
coefficients like i have here yet i need
to do a little more work
i'm going to get ax squared 4ax
4a and then all of this trailing stuff
okay right now have a look at it with me
okay for instance
have a look at that x squared term okay
now
what's the coefficient x squared over
here
it's one right now where could that one
possibly come from on the left-hand side
and there's there's nowhere else to look
except here there are no other x squared
terms
right there are ax squareds over there
and there is
oh i'm leaking there's one here okay
so a and one have to be the same
there's nowhere else the x squared terms
can come from
a must be one okay if you want you can
say
by comparison of coefficients
which is exactly what you do when you're
doing
auxiliary angle from scratch right you
expand this guy and then you say by
comparison of coefficients
because alpha equals blah blah blah okay
all right we got a so let's keep going
we'll go
up here um if i know a is one i've got x
squared plus
4x plus 4 plus bx
plus 2b plus c okay i've already
accounted for the x squared terms
how many x terms are there on the right
hand side
there are none but i have some floating
around here
right so that must mean that here's one
and here's the other whatever they are
they must leave me with
zero lots of x right because that's what
i end up with
right so here let me make it a little
more obvious to you by factorizing
there's my x squared hanging out the
front how many lots of x do i have
b plus 4 lots
no because i've already dealt with a i
know what a is
right and of course you need to because
otherwise you've just got too many
variables flying around
okay so b plus 4x plus what do i have
left here 2b
plus c plus 4. okay you can see where
it's going now can't you okay
b plus four by comparison of
coefficients must be zero
so there's your value for b okay
one more time so we can finish it off x
squared
where was i i was here wasn't it um
i've actually already dealt with all the
x's so i'm just going to worry about
these guys here
plus 2 times negative 4
that's b plus c plus 4 that's equivalent
to x squared plus 2. okay
so all of these guys must equal 2
because that's the constant terms
there's nowhere else where they can come
from
okay so that's actually c
minus 4
okay so now i know what my a and b
and c are i can say what f x is
f of x right there's f of x plus two
there right now i replace all the x plus
twos with x's
a is one b is minus four
and c was